ON WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS IS
HIS PLAN TO LOWER COSTS FOR
AMERICAN FAMILIES.
>> JOBS ARE BACK.
PRICES ARE STILL TOO HIGH.
COVID IS DOWN, BUT GAS PRICES
ARE UP.
OUR WORK ISN'T DONE.
>> SOARING INFLATION SHOWING FEW
SIGNS OF EASING UP, A STUBBORN
ECONOMIC AND POLITICAL PROBLEM
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> IT'S NEVER BEEN THIS HIGH.
>> GAS PRICES AVERAGING A
WHOPPING $5 A GALLON FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
THE U.S. STOCK MARKET TUMBLING
INTO BEAR MARKET TERRITORY.
AND THE COST OF CONSUMER GOODS
RISING AT THE FASTEST PACE IN
FOUR DECADES.
>> I HAVE A PLAN TO BRING DOWN
THE COST OF GAS AND FOOD.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE TIME.
>> THE PRESIDENT TRAVELING TO
PHILADELPHIA TODAY TO ONCE AGAIN
ADDRESS THOSE ECONOMIC ISSUES.
BIDEN IN PART BLAMING THE WAR IN
UKRAINE FOR RECORD HIGH GAS
PRICES.
>> I AM DOING EVERYTHING IN MY
POWER TO BLUNT PUTIN'S GAS PRICE
HIKE.
JUST SINCE HE INVADED UKRAINE,
IT'S GONE UP $1.74 A GALLON.
>> AS WELL AS REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS WHO ARE OPPOSING HIS
LEGISLATIVE AGENDA.
>> THE PROBLEM IS, REPUBLICANS
IN CONGRESS ARE DOING EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO STOP MY PLANS TO
BRING DOWN COSTS ON ORDINARY
FAMILIES.
THE FACT IS REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS ARE STILL IN THE GRIP
OF THE ULTRA MAGA AGENDA.
>> BIDEN ALSO TRYING TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE BRIGHT
SPOTS IN THE ECONOMY.
>> SINCE I HAVE BECOME
PRESIDENT, WE HAVE CREATED 8.7
MILLION NEW JOBS IN 16 MONTHS,
AN ALL-TIME RECORD.
OUR UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS NEAR
HISTORIC LOWS.
3.7%.
>> STILL, A YEAR AND A HALF INTO
THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY, THE
REALITY GROWING INCREASINGLY
CLEAR.
INFLATION IS STILL FAR FROM
ABATING.
LAST YEAR, BIDEN AND OTHER TOP
OFFICIALS HAD INCORRECTLY
PREDICTED THAT HIGH PRICES WOULD
BE A PASSING PHENOMENON.
>> BY THE WAY, TALK OF
INFLATION, THE OVERWHELMING
CONSENSUS IS IT'S GOING TO POP
UP A LITTLE BIT AND THEN GO BACK
DOWN.
>> BIDEN INSISTING IN RECENT
DAYS HE WILL GIVE THE FEDERAL
RESERVE AMPLE ROOM TO DO ITS
WORK.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO INTERFERE
WITH THEIR CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
WORK.
>> THE CENTRAL BANK NOW POISED
TO INCREASE INTEREST RATES BY
.75% THIS WEEK, MARKING THE
BIGGEST SINGLE HIKE SINCE 1994.
NOW, IT JUST GIVES YOU A SENSE
OF HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE TO TRY TO LOWER GAS
PRICES THAT IT'S NOW ANNOUNCED
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
BE TRAVELING TO SAUDI ARABIA, OF
COURSE, ONE OF THE BIGGEST OIL
PRODUCERS IN THE WORLD.
AND THE PRESIDENT, THE WHITE
HOUSE CONFIRMED, IS GOING TO BE
MEETING WITH THE SAUDI CROWN
PRINCE, MOHAMMED BIN SALMAN,
WHILE HE'S THERE.
THIS IS SO SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THE PAST STATEMENTS
WE HAVE HEARD FROM THIS
PRESIDENT ABOUT WANTING TO MAKE
SAUDI ARABIA A PARIAH STATE,
WANTING IT TO PAY A PRICE AFTER
THE GRUESOME MURDER OF
JOURNALIST JAMAL KHASHOGGI.
THE PRESIDENT NOW GETTING A LOT
OF CRITICISM AND A LOT OF HEAT
FOR THIS DECISION.
SOME DEMOCRATS EVEN SAYING HE
MIGHT WANT TO RECONSIDER AND NOT
GO ON THIS TRIP AT ALL.
JAKE.
>> M.J. LEE AT THE WHITE HOUSE
FOR US, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THE FEDERAL RESERVE'S MONTHLY
MEETING KICKS OFF TODAY AMIDST
SKY HIGH INFLATION, AND NOW SOME
INVESTORS ARE GROWING
INCREASINGLY WORRIED THE FED
MIGHT DO SOMETHING IT HAS NOT
DONE IN NEARLY THREE DECADES.
RAHEL SOLOMON JOINS US NOW.
THE ISSUE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ISN'T NECESSARILY THE
POSSIBILITY OF RAISING INTEREST
RATES.
IT'S THE FED DOING SO BY .75.
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN FOR
AMERICANS?
>> ESSENTIALLY IT MEANS THE COST
OF BORROWING HAS GONE UP.
NOT JUST FOR US CONSUMERS BUT
ALSO AMERICAN COMPANIES AND
BUSINESSES.
THAT EATS INTO THEIR PROFITS.
BUT FOR US CONSUMERS, YES, THAT
MEANS THE COST TO BORROW FOR
PRACTICALLY ANYTHING IS GOING
HIGHER.
CREDIT CARD EXAMPLE IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE.
A STUDENT LOAN, CAR LOANS, AND
MORTGAGE LOANS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT MORTGAGE
LOANS.
THE AVERAGE 30-YEAR NOW HOVERING
AROUND 6%.
LAST THURSDAY, WE SPOKE ABOUT
THE AVERAGE 30-YEAR HITTING
ABOUT 5.3%, SO THAT GIVES YOU A
SENSE OF HOW DRAMATICALLY RATES
HAVE RISEN IN JUST A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME, AND THEN
CONSIDER THE FACT THAT IN THE
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR, RATES
WERE CLOSER TO 3%, A DRAMATIC
SPIKE, BUT REALLY ALL ACROSS THE
BOARD WITH THE FED RAISING
RATES, AND THAT'S EXACTLY THE
POINT.
THE FED IS TRYING TO CURB
DEMAND.
IT IS TRYING TO CURB SPENDING,
AND THAT'S WHAT RAISING RATES
DO.
>> YEAH, LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE OUR VIEWERS MIGHT BE
CONFUSED.
THE FED RAISES INTEREST RATES,
MAKES THINGS MORE EXPENSIVE.
HOW DOES THAT HELP LOWER
INFLATION?
>> IT DOES APPEAR A BIT
COUNTERINTUITIVE.
THE IDEA ESSENTIALLY IS THAT WE
HAVE A SUPPLY AND DEMAND
IMBALANCE.
TOO MUCH MONEY CHASING TOO FEW
GOODS.
THE FEDERAL RESERVE CAN'T DO
MUCH ABOUT SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES
DISRUPTING SUPPLIESIC BUT WHAT
IT CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT IS THE
DEMAND FOR GOODS.
SO IT'S MAKING THE DEMAND, IT IS
HOPING AT LEAST TO SORT OF CURB
DEMAND BY MAKING BORROWING MORE
EXPENSIVE.
JUST THINK, IF YOU WERE PAYING
MORE FOR A MORTGAGE RIGHT NOW
THAN LAST YEAR, MAYBE YOU'LL
RETHINK PERHAPS BUYING THE HOME,
OR MAYBE YOU'LL RETHINK GOING
OUT TO EAT, RETHINK GOING
SHOPPING.
THE IDEA IS TO HOPEFULLY PULL
THE ECONOMY AND THE HOPE IS THEY
CAN DO IT GENTLY AND GRADUALLY
WITHOUT A SCREECHING HALT.
>> AND RAHEL, TODAY, NEW DATA
SHOWED THAT THE PRODUCER PRICE
INDEX, THE PPI, REMAINS
UNCOMFORTABLY HIGH OVER 10%.
THE PPI IS ANOTHER KEY INFLATION
MEASURE.
EXPLAIN HOW IT AFFECTS WHAT WE
PAY AT THE STORE.
>> IT'S A KEY INFLATION MEASURE,
JAKE, BUT ITS ARE ONE THAT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION BECAUSE THIS IS
INFLATION ESSENTIALLY FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF PRODUCERS, RIGHT,
OR FACTORY LEVEL INFLATION.
SO THE IDEA, HOWEVER, AND THE
REASON WHY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TODAY IS WHAT WE SEE HERE TENDS
TO TRICKLE DOWN TO CONSUMERS A
FEW MONTHS DOWN THE LINE.
WE KNOW WHAT COMPANIES ARE
EXPERIENCING, THEY TEND TO
SOMETIMES PASS OFF TO US
CONSUMERS.
AND SO THE IDEA HERE LENDING
SOME SUPPORT THAT THERE MAY NOT
BE RELIEF FOR INFLATION AND FOR
CONSUMERS IN THE NEAR TERM.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHY MAHOLM
ELARIAN, WHO SPOKE ON CNN THIS
MORNING, HE SEES INFLATION
HITTING 9% IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS.
CERTAINLY NOT ANYTHING ANYONE
WANTS TO HEAR.
>> LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH
MATTHEW SLAUGHTER, DEAN OF
DARTMOUTH COLLEGE'S SCHOOL OF
BUSINESS.
MATTHEW, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS BEEN SAYING
INFLATION IS A TOP PRIORITY FOR
HIM TO TACKLE SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF MAY.
THE REALITY IS AMERICANS
CONTINUE TO FACE RECORD HIGH GAS
PRICES, MASSIVE INFLATION,
HIGHER PRICES ON EVERYDAY GOODS
SUCH AS GROCERIES.
WHAT COULD THE PRESIDENT DO
RIGHT NOW THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY
LOWER PRICES?
>> WELL, ONE THING HE'S ALREADY
DONE THAT'S IMPORTANT IS
ALLOWING THE FEDERAL RESERVE TO
DO ITS JOB.
SO AS RAHEL WAS JUST RIGHTLY
SAYING, THE CHALLENGE FOR THE
U.S. ECONOMY RIGHT NOW IS
AGGREGATE DEMAND HAS BEEN
GROWING MUCH MORE THAN AGGREGATE
SUPPLY CAN BE GROWING.
WHAT THE FED IS TRYING TO DO IS
TO RAISE THE COST OF BORROWING
TO HOUSEHOLDS AND TO BUSINESSES,
AND THEREBY TO CUT INTO
HOUSEHOLD SPENDING, TO CUT INTO
CAPITAL INVESTMENT BY COMPANIES
AND COOL THE HOUSING MARKET AS
WELL.
THOUGH THINGS WILL HELP LOWER
AGGREGATE DEMAND.
I THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT ALSO,
WHAT THE PRESIDENT CAN DO,
THINKING ABOUT ENERGY PRICES IN
PARTICULAR, ONE THING THAT
HASN'T BEEN DONE QUITE AS MUCH
AS TRYING TO STIMULATE DOMESTIC
PRODUCTION.
ALLOWING US TO PRODUCE MUCH MORE
ENERGY IN THE UNITED STATES,
MUCH MORE THAN TEN OR 20 YEARS
AGO.
SO LET THE FED DO ITS JOB.
THINK ABOUT DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
THOSE WOULD BE TWO THINGS I
WOULD START WITH.
>> ANOTHER IDEA THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED
AS BEING UNDER CONSIDERATION
WOULD BE PRESIDENT BIDEN LIFTING
THE TRUMP ERA TARIFFS AGAINST
CHINA TO HELP LOWER INFLATION.
BIDEN, OF COURSE, HAS BEEN LONG
THROUGHOUT HIS ENTIRE CAREER, A
UNION ADVOCATE.
HIS SPEECH TODAY WAS AT THE
AFL-CIO CONVENTION IN PHILLY, A
GATHERING OF UNION LEADERS.
UNIONS REPORTEDLY WANT TO KEEP
ALL THE TARIFFS IN PLACE.
HOW MUCH OF A DIFFERENCE WOULD
LIFTING TARIFFS MAKE FOR THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN?
>> THEY WOULD HELP A LITTLE BIT,
AND I THINK, JAKE, THAT'S A
GREAT YIEZ YOU RAISE.
I WOULD ADD THAT TO THE LIST AS
A THIRD ONE.
A LOT OF THE RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT THOSE TARIFFS, HOWEVER WELL
INTENTIONED TO TRY TO HELP
AMERICAN WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES, THE COSTS WERE BORN
PRECISELY BY AMERICAN WORKERS
AND FAMILIES.
COSTS HAVE BEEN HIGHER IN A LOT
OF THE PRODUCTS THAT USE
INTENSIVELY ALUMINUM AND STEEL
AND SOME OF THE OTHER PRODUCTS
SUBJECT TO THE CHINESE TARIFFS.
GLOBALIZATION IN GENERAL HAS
BEEN PART OF WHAT CONTROLS THE
COST OF LIVING FROM INCREASING
AS MUCH.
THAT'S BEEN TRUE FOR DECADES.
THE CHINESE TARIFFS MESSED UP